cupcakes they come in a variety of
colors and flavors some simple others
more fancy either way cupcakes veen
cells three thousand cupcakes a day in
its three cafes in 2010 renata gruba
added cupcakes to vienna's dessert
repertoire at the time the miniature
colorfully decorated cakes were still
largely unknown in Austria hit the mini
market box listen you and I never would
have thought that in Vienna the pastry
capital anyone would be interested in
eating a new type of sweet phone this is
Catherine Suh SC cupcakes originated in
the United States and spread to Europe
via Britain Renata Gruber discovered the
tiny sweet treats while on holiday in
London
at the time she was working as a graphic
designer and running an advertising
agency in Vienna the colorful designs of
cupcakes fascinated her man allegedly
had the humor so on this geeky elmsford
my passion has always been creating
beautiful designs my original profession
was graphic design with my career I
decided I wanted to make nice things in
principle I've remained true to my
profession and my passion I just changed
the medium instead of designing on paper
I use edible materials cupcakes and
torts it's bad methionine passing even
ones that I cupcakes and puffy renata
Gruber has made a name for herself in
Vienna
she's considered Austria's first cupcake
designer
shortly after teaching herself how to
bake she wrote a book of cupcake recipes
roughly translated as a hundred and
thirty grams of love it became the
German language standard for cupcakes
and sold out three times in 2012 its
first year to maintain her status as
vienna's cupcake queen Renata sometimes
turns up to give readings in her mobile
cupcake van the captain's man was funny
thing hopi food originally cupcakes were
just a hobby on the first day I opened
up in two hours later we were sold out
and it's kept going that way she opened
her third shop in 2013 in vienna's
Museum quarter this cupcake restaurant
serves both warm cakes and savory dishes
as well her facebook page cupcakes bean
has around 50,000 likes and her bacon
courses are booked out well in advance
when it comes to calories Renata's
little treats are definitely heavy
weights they didn t enough calories when
people ask about calories we just say
happiness has no calories hot kanika
loving her latest cookbook isn't for
dieters either but as they say all good
things come in small packages